hi herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF F live
schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid wir
gucken hier heute in unserem Ukraine
Update auf die aktuelle Lage an der
Front und auf die Ergebnisse des letzten
EU-Gipfels und wir werfen auch einen
Blick in die Ukraine zu dieser
Jahreszeit denn auch das ist Kiev in
diesen Tagen ihr seht die Stadt leuchtet
und glitzert 22 Monate ist jetzt schon
her dass Russland seinen Angriffskrieg
gegen die Ukraine gestartet hat und der
Krieg ist zum traurigen Alltag geworden
die Weihnachtsbeleuchtung sorgt in der
Hauptstadt zumindest kurz für etwas
Ablenkung vom russischen Überfall
während an der Frontlinie wie hier in
afdivka weiter erbittert gekämpft wird
ohne aber dass es große Geländegewinne
gibt auf der einen oder auf der anderen
Seite ja und russlands Präsident Putin
der gab sich gestern Abend im
Staatsfernsehen gewohnt selbst
die Ukraine produziert fast nichts mehr
selbst alles wird kostenlos
geliefert aber das könnte
Enden der Präsident Putin hat eigentlich
keinen Grund so selbstbewusst zu sein
das sagt unser Gast Markus K von der ETH
Zürich EU Beitrittsgespräche die Lage an
der Front veraltete Panzer wasind ell
Putins Probleme über die wollen wir
heute sprechen zum einen mit Markus Kolb
mit dem militärökonomen aber auch mit
ZDF Korrespondent Tim Kröger in Kiev und
wie immer auch mit euch vor den
Bildschirmen wenn ihr Fragen zum Thema
habt oder eure Meinung mit uns teilen
wollt dann tut das wie immer sehr gerne
hier im Youtube Chat oder per Mail an
die unten
eingeblendete Adresse jetzt schauen wir
aber erstmal auf die aktuelle Lage an
der Front und das tun wir gemeinsam mit
militärökonom Markus Kolb der uns aus
Zürich zugeschaltet ist guten Abend Herr
Kolb hallo guten Abend Herr KB wir haben
es gerade schon gehört so richtig viel
Bewegung gibt es an der Front nicht sie
sagen da ja immer auch oft in unseren
Sendungen das ist eigentlich gar nicht
so wichtig man muss vor allem gucken was
militärisch im Hintergrund passiert
jetzt lassen Sie uns mal auf aftiifka
gucken der Ort wird ja aktuell verstärkt
angegriffen einige Experten sagen
aktuell dass das Momentum ziemlich in
Richtung Russland Kippe die Ukraine
brauchen neben Artillerie und Luftwaffe
derzeit vor allem Munition warum sind
sie trotzdem
optimistisch auch vereinfacht gesagt
weil ich auf die Karte schaue und mich
an die Fakten halte und nicht an an die
medialen Erzählungen oder ans
Bauchgefühl ähm vielleicht können wir
die Karte gleich mal Einblenden von auf
die jeevka dann dann kann ich da ein
paar Punkte dazu sagen worum es
eigentlich geht ähm genau hier sehen wir
es gerade ähm man muss sich vorstellen
dass äh auf die jivka äh hier sehen wir
sehr schön so wie ein wie ein Sporn in
die russischen Linien hineinragt und das
ist an der gesamten südöstlichen Front
der mit Abstand stärkst am stärksten
befestigte Punkt also sprich hier hat
die Ukraine ähm massiv
Verteidigungslinien Bunker verbundene
Grabensysteme und so weiter alles mit
Beton ausgegossen also da durchzukommen
ähm das ist sehr sehr schwer für die
Russen ähm das ist übrigens nicht erst
seit der Invasion so das ist schon seit
Minsk i also seit 2015 war erst die jfka
an der kontaktlinie ähm jetzt haben die
Russen ähm seit Anfang Oktober also laut
der Ukraine seit dem 1en laut den Russen
seit dem 10 Oktober einen massiven
mechanisierten Angriff gestartet gegen
AF die jeevka
per heute 1 nein Entschuldigung per 10
Dezember das war mein letzter Zählstand
äh haben Sie mindestens 311 schwere
Fahrzeuge also Panzer ähm Artillerie äh
Inf Fahrzeuge und so weiter ähm verloren
ähm also diese 311 die sind bestätigt
mit mit Videos wie wir sie hier sehen
oder mit mit Bildbeweis und
geolokalisiert ähm Verschiebungen an der
Frontlinie hat es kaum gegeben ähm es
hat kleinere Vorstöße der Russen an der
nördlichen
Flanke dieses Gebiets gegeben also sie
sind etwas über die Bahnlinie
vorgedrungen man kann aber nicht
wirklich sagen ähm dass das mit mit
massiver Kraft geschehen ist also es
gibt kleine Team die sich quasi den den
baumlinien entlang da
Vorarbeiten und dann kommen die Ukrainer
verfolgen sie mit drohen schlagen sie
wieder ein bisschen zurück also im
Norden gibt es kleine geländeewinner der
Russen aber
die stehen in keinem Verhältnis zu den
massiven mechanisierten Verlusten im
Süden gibt es überhaupt keine
wesentliche Verschiebung dieser
Frontlinie also insofern muss man sagen
die Russen machen das gleiche was sie
eigentlich auch schon im Januar und
Februar diesen Jahres gemacht haben also
das ist jetzt fast 12 Monate her aber im
Prinzip ja man man kann dankbar sein
dass gerasimow immer noch das
hauptkommando hat das ist eigentlich ein
der arbeitet sehr gut der Ukraine zu
indem er sowas macht
nämlich indem Russland seine seine
Reserven hier reinschickt und
operativ dem keine wirklichen
Geländegewinne entgegenstehen sie haben
diesen Angriff dann abgebrochen ähm also
den mechanisierten Angriff und haben ihn
ersetzt durch einen Angriff mit mobix
und mit Sträflingen also sprich mit der
russischen Methode diese Menschen äh die
die sind nicht so wertvoll die können
wir opfern das ist so wie in der
zaristischen Zeit ne das ist unser
treues Vieh das rennt dann in die Linien
und äh sie versuchen es also seither mit
äh mit massierten personellen Angriffen
die funktionieren allerdings auch nicht
also die Russen verlieren je nachdem
wenn sie jetzt glauben so zwischen 400
und 800 Mann pro Tag allein in diesem
Abschnitt Russland ist nach wie vor der
Überzeugung es könne diese Verluste
hinnehmen ähm nur was ich immer sage
auch hier wieder Gruß an meine
russentrolle wenn sie wenn sie wieder
das Märchen von den unendlichen
russischen Reserven verbreiten russland
steht nicht über den Gesetzen der Physik
Reserven schmelzen ab ja Reserven müssen
ersetzt werden und irgendwann sind die
ersatzfähigen Reserven ausgeschossen und
beim beim Personal wird sich das ähnlich
einstellen also in dem Sinne sage ich
immer vergessen Sie Ihr Bauchgefühl ja
sondern schauen Sie sich die Fakten wir
haben zu direkt eine Frage aus der
Community da fragt jemand was ist
notwendig damit die Ukraine bei afdivka
die Russen zurückdrängen kann
Artilleriemunition und zwar viel davon
das ist im Moment für beide Seiten ein
großes Problem sowohl für die Russen
weil ihre
vorkriegsartilleriebestände sich auch
langsam dem Ende zu neigen also von den
ca 17 Millionen Artilleriegranaten mit
den Russland reingegangen ist in die
Invasion 22 sind mindestens 11 Millionen
verschossen das hat dazu geführt dass
die russische artilleriefrequenz massiv
tief gesunken ist auf jetzt noch etwa
9000 pro Tag die ukrainische liegt bei
etwa 5000 pro Tag ähm das reicht für die
Ukraine um die wichtigsten Räume zu
halten es reicht aber nicht um um
vorzurücken also im Sinne eines massiven
gegenstoßes das heißt Sie können diesen
diesen Krieg
nicht so nach Lehrbuch führen wo sie
also sagen erst kommt eine massive
artilleriewelle und dann kommt ein
großer mechanisierter Angriff äh man
muss andererseits sagen
wenn man die Ukraine entschiedener
unterstützen würde äh dann könnte man
sie durchaus in diese Lage versetzen
also es es gibt zwar im Moment ähm noch
äh etwas wenig produktivkapazität beim
Nachschub dieser Artillerie aber da ist
man gerade die auf dabei die aufzubauen
es gibt ähm aber genügend andere Art von
Munition die bisher zwar geliefert wird
aber jetzt nicht in massivem Umfang und
da fällt mir ein ähm ich werde ja
manchmal im Internet ähm verglichen mit
einem gewissen österreichischen Oberst
und es wird manchmal so dargestellt dass
sein wir quasi zwei zwei verschiedene
Pole ja oder zwei Personen die völlig
gegensätzliche Dinge sagen das ist
überhaupt nicht so wir sagen eigentlich
im Moment genau das gleiche was man der
Ukraine liefert das reicht um die Front
zu halten es reicht aber nicht um die
Ukraine in einen massiven Zustand der
Offensive zu versetzen also in einem
Zustand dass sie den Krieg tatsächlich
gewinnt und
da muss man sich dann halt irgendwann
klar werden was man eigentlich will ja
äh sie sprechen hier von Oberst Reisner
den kennt ihr sicher auch wenn ihr öfter
mal ZDF heute live schaut lassen s uns
mal ein bisschen auf ein anderen
Abschnitt an der Front gucken im Süden
am denirpro da haben sie uns eine Karte
mitgebracht mit den Ortschaften oleschki
und krinki die werden wir jetzt
einblenden und da ist der Herr Kolb Weg
das war jetzt so nicht geplant hoffe er
ist uns gleich wieder
zugeschaltet hier sehen wir schon mal
diesen
Frontabschnitt um den es geht Herr Kolb
können Sie mich noch
hören nee Herr Kolb kann mich nicht mehr
hören dann doch jetzt ist er wieder da
hallo Herr KB schön dass wieder bei un
sind alles gut genau dann lassen Sie uns
doch mal gemeinsam auf diesen
Frontabschnitt im Süden gucken am denpro
mit den zwei Ortschaften krinki und
oleski und da bräuchte ich einmal noch
die Karte
dafür ja aber das sind erstmal nur ich
und Herr Kolb vielleicht können Sie uns
einmal so erzählen bis wir die Karte
sehen was sich gerade an diesem
Frontabschnitt tut bzw wie sich das
entwickelt was das Besondere ist genau
ähm ja der der ganze Frontabschnitt ist
eigentlich bemerkenswert weil da etwas
passiert das eigentlich nicht passieren
dürfte also was passiert ist seit dem
Sommer ist das langsame Einsickern von
ukrainischen Spezialkräften also von
leicht bewaffneten Kräften
ohne wirklich schwere Systeme ähm und äh
die sind so über den Sommer haben die
angefangen so K kine Erkundungstouren
mit dem Boot zu machen an manchen Orten
hat es geklappt an anderen nicht aber
das Interessante ist dass es zwischen
oleski und krinki eine Lücke gibt in dem
in den russischen Gräben die dort unten
an der südwestfront stehen also man muss
wissen das ist eine Ecke dies die
sovikin als er seine ganzen Gräben
gebaut hat entlang der Front so ein
bisschen ausgespart hat nämlich in der
Erwartung na ja also durch die durch
dieses Sumpfgebiet und und an diesem
schlammigen Ufer da werden sie nicht
anlanden oder wenn dann werden wir sie
da wieder zurück
werfen und deswegen gibt es da nicht so
viele statische Befestigung im Gelände
das hat die Ukraine ausgenutzt und
dort sich tatsächlich etablieren können
man muss sagen also mit sehr wenig
Leuten das sind etwa 400 Spezialkräfte
die dort stehen und parallel haben sie
eben drohenoperateure und vom
gegenüberliegenden Ufer des Nepo schießt
die Artillerie und äh
überraschenderweise können die sich
nicht nur in krinky halten sondern sie
können sogar sich so langsam vorarbeiten
also sie kontrollieren jetzt einen Teil
ähm der des Ortes krinki und ähm sind
gerade dabei einen weiteren Teil in
einem weiteren Teil vorzurücken der wird
von den Russen beschossen seit 13
Dezember was signalisiert dass sie
diesen Teil nicht mehr kontrollieren
wenn Sie jetzt auf die Karte schauen da
sehen sie die beiden zentralen
versorgungsachsen der südwestlichen
russischen Front nämlich diese beiden na
ja nennen wir sie nennen wir sie
vielleicht nicht Autobahn nennen wir sie
Landstraßen M14 und M17 über die M14
kommt der Nachschub aus Melitopol und
über die M17 von amjansk also von der
Krim und sie sehen jetzt die Idee ähm
wenn Sie diese beiden Straßen
kontrollieren können also mit Artillerie
beschießen können dann können Sie den
Russen den Nachschub abschneiden und
zwar nicht nur da sondern an der
gesamten südwestfront sie müssen sich
also vorstellen dass die russischen
Truppen äh im Moment konzentriert stehen
also entlang dieser rot eingezeichneten
Linie im Hinterland steht so gut wie
nichts mehr ähm und das können Sie
natürlich jetzt ausnutzen also sprich
wenn es ihnen gelingen würde diese
beiden Straßen zu kontrollieren die
Ukraine beschießt bereits die M14 von
krinki aus also da da ist bereits
teilweise
artilleriekontrolle dann sehen Sie wie
das ganze funktioniert ne sie schneiden
damit den gesamten südwestlichen Sektor
also alles was westlich dieser
Verbindungsstraße liegt von oleski nach
amjansk alles was westlich davon liegt
das würden sie abschneiden und die die
russischen Truppen werden dann entweder
gezwungen zum Rückzug auf die Krim oder
t sie sie könnten sich dort jedenfalls
nicht mehr halten also sie müssten sich
äh irgendwohin äh absetzen und
ähm im Sommer haben das wirklich wenige
Analysten ähm ernst genommen dass da
etwas Ernsthaftes draus entstehen könnte
ähm die meisten haben gesagt ich damals
auch im im Sommer ja das ist vielleicht
ein Ablenkungsmanöver oder vielleicht so
ein so ein Erkundungsmission ähm aber es
hat sich eben jetzt in in ein sich
festsetzen und ein sich ausbauen dieser
Position entwickelt ich möchte immer
noch nicht wirklich von Brückenkopf
sprechen weil dafür müssten die Ukrainer
noch schwere Systeme nachschieben aber
das wirklich überraschende ist dass es
den Russen nicht gelingt ähm diese diese
paar Leute die da stehen wieder
zurückzuwerfen über den nipo und es
passiert noch was anderes nämlich die
drohenoperateureen die da stehen nehmen
jetzt pö pö auch schwere russische
Systeme raus also wir beobachten
zunehmend Abschüsse von schwerem
russischen Gerät in diesem Bereich
zwischen krinky und der Straße M14 das
dürfte eigentlich nicht passieren also
die Russen müssten eigentlich reingehen
mit einem mit einem konzertierten
Angriff also da sindmer wieder beim
Stichwort Kampf der verbundenen Waffen
das tun sie aber nicht sondern sie
schicken einzelne Fahrzeuge vor und
diese Fahrzeuge werden dann von FPV
drones die wir hier gerade sehen
abgeschossen und rausgenommen und sie
können sich vorstellen wenn es jetzt
eine Zeit lang so weitergeht und es der
Ukraine gelingt entlang dieser
Küstenstraße also zwischen krinki und
oleski eine dauerhafte Kontrolle zu
etablieren dann können Sie sich in
dieses Waldgebiet zurückziehen zwischen
dem nipro und der der Straße M14 weil
wenn sie mal in diesem Waldgebiet drin
sind ist das sehr schwer die zu finden
und da wieder
rauszudrücken und dann
hätten sie tatsächlich vollständige
logistische Kontrolle
man muss auch noch eine sehen
ich habe immer gesagt ich bin das
häufiger gefragt worden im Sommer ja wie
wahrscheinlich ist es denn dass die
Ukraine irgendwann über den pnipro
übersetzt also quasi eine amphibische
Operation durchführt da habe ich immer
gesagt ähm schwierig bis
unwahrscheinlich weil solange die Russen
mit Artillerie drauf schießen können
solange wäre das Selbstmord wenn sie
jetzt aber das bedenken dass die Ukraine
sich da festsetzt die russische
Artillerie so über den Lauf von
vielleicht drei Monaten weitgehend
ausschaltet wenn sie jetzt wissen dass
die sowjetischen BMP Fahrzeuge die die
Ukraine auch hat dass die amphibisch
sind also die können da wirklich
durchschwimmen durch den Dipo ähm dann
könnte es der Ukraine gelingen so pö pö
schweres Fahrzeug einsickern zu lassen
das wäre also nicht wie im Zweiten
Weltkrieg dass sie so eine massive
so ein massiven Übergang machen oder
Pontonbrücke bauen sondern sie würden so
pöpö
die die Fahrzeuge einsickern lassen und
dann wirklich versuchen dort ein
Brückenkopf zu bilden und dann von
Südwesten aus direkt auf die Nordspitze
der Krim oder nach Osten in Richtung
Melitopol vorzustoßen das könnte also
eine Idee sein für die Ukraine für eine
größere Offensive im im Frühjahr 24 aber
bemerkenswert ist wirklich dass es den
Russen obwohl sie dort unten
konventionell wir überlegen stehen ja so
es stehen sieben Brigaden dort die sind
zwar nicht mehr voll kampffähig aber
trotzdem steht viel mehr russisches
Material als ukrainisches Material dort
und trotzdem gelingt es ihnen nicht
diese Leute zurückzuwerfen das ist
eigentlich das das überraschende an
diesem Raum wir haben zu diesem
Frontabschnitt auch noch eine Frage aus
der Community und zwar fragt jemand
glauben Sie dass es noch gelingen kann
die Versorgung der Krim abzuschneiden
für wie warscheinlich halten sie
das ach ich sag zu dem Thema immer das
das Motto ist ganz einfach das Motto
heißt Frieden schaffen durch
lenkflugwaffen
ähm also sprich das Thema ist nicht auf
die Krim vorzurücken das Thema ist die
Krim logistisch zu isolieren die Krim
ist für Russland das Herzstück der
militärischen Operation von da wird die
Logistik nachgeschoben von da starten
die Flugzeuge von da starten die
Hubschrauber das heißt ähm wenn Sie wenn
Sie die Krim treffen wollen dann müssen
sie einerseits die Straßen unterbinden
also und die Eisenbahnlinien also die
versorgungsachsen und zweitens müssen
Sie die luftkampfmittel herausnehmen
dafür haben sie stormshadow dafür haben
sie attackems und dafür haben sie Taurus
sofern das dann irgendwann mal geliefert
wird also spricht die die Mittel wären
im Prinzip da nur die Stückzahlen nicht
ja und da sind wir wieder bei dem was
ich vorhin gesagt habe es wäre kein
Problem rein logistisch gesehen die
Ukraine in in einen Zustand zu versetzen
wo sie wo sie das könnte ähm die Frage
ist halt ob der politische Wille da ist
ja und über die politischen
Voraussetzungen dafür sprechen wir
gleich noch mal Herr Kolb bis später
genau wir sprechen jetzt gleich mit
meinem Kollegen in Kiev es gab nämlich
in den letzten Tagen gute News für die
Ukraine beim letzten EU-Gipfel Ungarns
Premierminister Viktor Orban der gute
Verbindung zu kremelchef Putin pflegt
verließ hier gestern während der
Abstimmung über die Aufnahme von
Beitrittsverhandlungen mit der Ukraine
einfach den Sitzungssaal und die
restlichen 26 Staats- und
Regierungschefin stimmten dann ohne
Orban ab und zwar einstimmig für
Beitrittsgespräche Orban hält weder von
beitrittsgesprächen noch von Ukraine
Hilfen etwas beim zweiten Thema konnte
er sich aber durchsetzen gegen
Hilfszahlung in Höhe von 50 Milliarden
Euro legte Orban sein Veto ein und das
besprechen wir jetzt mit dem Kröger der
mir aus Kiev zugeschaltet guten Abend
Tim schön guten Abend ja ein sehr
zweischneidiges Schwert zum einen das ja
zu beitrittsverhandlung und das Nein zu
Milliarden Finanzhilfen wie blicken denn
die Ukrainer und Ukrainerinnen auf
dieses
gipfelergebnis na ja also schauen wir
erstmal auf diese Entscheidung dass es
jetzt
EU beitrittsverhandlung mit der Ukraine
geben soll das ist natürlich ein ganz
wichtiges Zeichen hier in die Ukraine
vor allem jetzt in dieser Situation wo
die Menschen sich weiterhin gegen
Russland wehren müssen wir haben hier
heute in der Innenstand von Kiev mit
einigen Menschen gesprochen und die
haben das sehr positiv aufgenommen die
haben gesagt es ist wichtig das gibt
Vertrauen
es macht Hoffnung auf die Zukunft ein
Mann hat uns gesagt dass es vor allem
eben auch wichtig ist dieses
zeichengesetetzt zu haben um dieses
Zeichen gleichzeitig nach Russland
weiterzugeben an Putin der dann ebenfall
versteht dass er eben doch nicht tun
kann was er will also die Menschen hier
in der Ukraine für die ist das glaube
ich ein sehr wichtiges Zeichen es ist
natürlich im Moment eher ein
symbolischer Akt es gibt noch viel zu
tun es geht eben wie gesagt erstmal nur
um Beitrittsverhandlungen und noch
längst nicht um den EU Beitritt aber es
ist auch das haben die Menschen gesagt
zumindest erstmal ein wichtiger Schritt
dann hat natürlich auch die ukrainische
führungsriegel hier sofort auf
verschiedenen Kanälen auf dieses
Ergebnis gestern Abend reagiert der
ukrainische Präsident selenski hat es
eine motivierende eine inspirierende
eine stärkende Entscheidung genannt aber
er hat eben auch noch mal deutlich
gemacht dass das wie gesagt jetzt
erstmal ein langer Weg ist der da vor
der Ukraine liegt vor allen eben viel
Arbeit die staatlichen Institutionen
müssen komplett umgebaut werden oder
zumindest deutlich reformiert werden um
sie eben in die Europäische Union zu
integrieren also die Ukrainer sowohl auf
der Führungsebene als auch die Menschen
mit denen wir ja auf der Straße
gesprochen haben den ist glaube ich
schon klar dass das erstmal nur ein
symbolisches Zeichen war aber es war
eben ein wichtiges dann gibt es
natürlich die Diskussion um die 50
Milliarden Euro dazu muss man sagen ähm
das sind nicht einfach nur Zuschüsse
sondern ein Drittel ungefähr sind
Zuschüsse der Rest sind Kredite die die
Ukraine bekommen soll aber diese
Finanzhilfen braucht die Ukraine eben
wirklich sehr dringend um einfach zu
überleben es ist so dass die Ukraine ein
Großteil der eigenen finanziellen Mittel
für das Militär für äh die
Selbstverteidigung ausgeben muss das
heißt es bleibt im Grunde nichts mehr
übrig um den Staatshaushalt ähm zu
betreiben also vor allem das öffentliche
Leben dafür werden diese Gelder vor
allem gebraucht also da geht's
beispielsweise um Gehälter ähm bei der
öffentlichen Verwaltung Ärzte Lehrer in
den sozialen Einrichtungen und es ist
auch so dass dieses Geld nicht ähm noch
also dass es noch genug Reserven gibt
sondern ähm es müsste wirklich bald
kommen damit die Ukraine nicht bankrott
läuft und ähm deswegen ist es halt
wichtig dass es doch vielleicht noch
irgendwann eine Entscheidung gibt im
Moment äh hören wir ja aus Brüssel dass
zumindest 26 Staaten innerhalb der EU
doch ähm davon überzeugt sind dass sie
dieses Geld freigeben wollen im
Januar soll noch mal verhandelt werden
also alle Augen hier richten sich jetzt
darauf was dann passieren wird aber die
Hoffnung ist eben groß dass am Ende
diese 50 Milliarden vianshilfen an die
Ukraine doch noch freigegeben werden ja
soweit also zur politischen Ebene ähm
jetzt stehst du da gerade in Kiev im
Dezember und dieser Krieg geht jetzt
schon eine ganze Weile wie erlebst du
denn gerade das zivile Leben das Leben
der Bürger und Bürgerinnen in der
Ukraine verglichen mit dem von vor einem
Jahr das hat sich schon deutlich
geändert also vor einem Jahr war ja die
Situation dass die russische Seite hier
massiv die Städte angegriffen hat
Heizkraftwerke
äh Elektrizitätswerke also wirklich
versucht hat die Infrastruktur die
kritische Infrastruktur zu treffen und
das ist auch teilweise gelungen damals
gab's hier Stromausfälle
die Wohnung waren kalt
damals waren aber auch die
psychologischen Vorgaben für die
Menschen trotzdem andere also im Herbst
vorvergangenen Jahres hatte die Ukraine
gerade bei chasson und bei chakiv zwei
sehr erfolgreiche offensiven
durchgeführt hat große Teile des Landes
zurückgewonnen das war natürlich auch
wenn die Situation damals in den Städten
und auch sonst eigentlich schwieriger
war so war doch die psychologische
Voraussetzung für die Ukrainer meiner
Meinung nach besser jetzt ist es so dass
ähm vor allem hier in den Städten das
Leben zumindest äußerlich relativ normal
ist die meisten Luftangriffe wie
beispielsweise gestern als Russland mit
hyperschallraketen angegriffen hat die
meisten Luftangriffe werden von dem
mittlerweile gut installierten
luftabwehrsystemen
ähm abgefangen das heißt also es geht
gar nicht mehr eine so große Gefahr
davon aus wie noch vor einem Jahr
natürlich fallen immer wieder
Trümmerteile herab die dann Schäden und
auch verletzte manchmal tote nach sich
ziehen aber es ist eben kein Vergleich
zum vergangenen Jahr insofern
ist die äußerliche Situation jetzt etwas
besser aber die psychologische ist
meiner Ansicht nach doch eine andere
denn im Sommer gab es noch vor der
Sommeroffensive doch große Hoffnung dass
eventuell in diesem Krieg einen
Durchbruch geschafft werden kann damals
war die internationale Hilfe riesengroß
es wurden Brigaden auf aufgebaut es
wurden Waffen geliefert aber aus dieser
Hoffnung ist eben nicht viel geworden
und von der Hoffnung ist jetzt auch
nicht mehr viel zu spüren jetzt ist eben
eher der Eindruck hier in der Ukraine
dass die internationale Hilfe vielleicht
nicht versiegt aber doch das Ringen
darum schwieriger wird das hat man im
Kongress gesehen bei den Amerikanern das
hat man jetzt auf EU-Ebene auch wieder
gesehen und das kriegen die Menschen
natürlich hier mit und deswegen fehlt ih
so ein bisschen im Moment das ist meine
Meinung die Perspektive wie es in diesem
Krieg weitergeht der ja mittlerweile
Weile seit fast Z Jahren geht also das
ist so mein Eindruck dass im Moment die
Atmosphäre die die Gefühle der Menschen
eher dahinehen dass sie sich danach
sehen dass sie irgendwie eine Zukunft
eine Perspektive in diesem Krieg
haben du warst ja auch auf einer Demo
von Müttern von Soldaten die aktuell an
der Front kämpfen wofür haben die da
demonstriert was hast du da
erlebt genau das ist etwas was jetzt
hier schon mehrfach in Kiev äh
stattgefunden hat das sind Proteste von
Ehefrauen von Männern die als Soldaten
an der Front dienen der Hintergrund ist
dass das Männer sind die sich meist
schon vor fast zwei Jahren freiwillig
gemeldet haben also nach dem
Großangriff der russischen Seite nach
dem 24 Februar
2022 diese Soldaten sind mittlerweile
seit weit über anderthalb Jahren im
Einsatz
sie sind sehr erschöpft und die Frauen
demonstrieren eben dafür dass Ihre m
Männer die sich damals freiwillig
gemeldet haben oder auch eingezogen
worden sind dass sie eine Perspektive
haben wann sie von der Front
zurückkehren können im Moment ist es so
dass das eigentlich im Grunde nicht
limitiert ist solange das Kriegsrecht
gilt und sie verlangen eben dass das
reduziert wird auf 18 Monate sie
verlangen natürlich auch dass dafür
vielleicht dann auch mal andere Männer
an die Front gehen Menschen die im
Moment noch von einer Einberufung von
einer Rekrutierung verschont geblieben
sind und dafür demonstrieren sie und es
ist deswegen interessant weil diese
Frauen natürlich auch erzählen wie es
ihne ihren Männern geht dass sie wie ich
es eben schon gesagt habe nach diesen
anderthalb Jahren teilweise auch
erschöpft sind dass sie teilweise
dass ihre Moral sinkt das ganze ist
natürlich sehr interessant und das
zwingt im Grunde auch die führungsriegel
hier in Kiev in der Ukraine zum Umdenken
sie müssen endlich sich auf einen
längeren Krieg einstellen und dafür eine
Lösung finden also beispielsweise wie
sie unter den Soldaten mehr Rotation
hinbekommen da gibt es jetzt auch schon
erste Schritte es gibt schon seit
längerer Zeit einzelne Brigaden die die
Rekrutierung von Soldaten selbst in die
Hand nehmen es gibt hier überall in Kiev
große Plakate wo um Soldaten geworben
wird und dann gibt es jetzt mittlerweile
aber auch unter dem neuen
Verteidigungsminister umerov einen
Vertrag mit rekrutierungsfirmen die zwar
schon vorher gearbeitet haben aber jetzt
eben auch mit dem Segen des
Verteidigungsministeriums die gezielter
und auch effektiver versuchen
Männer für die Front zu winnen da geht
es darum dass diese Männer wenn sie sich
denn auf konkrete Stellen von Einheiten
bewerben wirklich wissen wo sie
hinkommen in welcher Funktion sie sein
werden und Sie können auch nach ihren
Schwächen und Stärken besser eingesetzt
werden und Sie können z.B auch danach
eingesetzt werden wie viel Risiko sie
eingehen wollen oder eben nicht das ist
ein Versuch dann gibt es auch den
Versuch bei den öffentlichen also den
staatlichen rekrutierungsämtern äh
Reformen durchzuführen das alles soll
dazu dazu führen dass eben die Männer
die im Moment an der Front s langfristig
irgendwann mal zurückgeholt werden
können dass es mehr Rotationen geben
wird und dafür demonstrieren diese
Frauen hier in Kiev
Tim danke für deine Eindrücke aus Kiev
und alles Gute für dich schönen Abend
noch ja und über die Bedeutung dieser
Ergebnisse vom EU Gipfel für die Ukraine
und für den Krieg spreche ich jetzt noch
mal mit Markus Kolb der uns wieder
zugeschaltet ist aus zyrich
Herr K wir haben es eben schon kurz
angeschnitten
zum Ende ihres ersten Blogs wo sie
gesagt haben ja wenn man die Ukraine mal
so ausstatten würde dann könnte sie XY Z
jetzt frage ich was kann die Ukraine
denn noch ausrichten wenn ihn diese
Unterstützung aktuell fehlt sowohl in
den USA als auch in der EU hängen diese
Hilfen ja aktuell
m ja also man man muss eines ganz klar
sagen und vielleicht habe ich das in der
Vergangenheit zu wenig deutlich gesagt
also allen meinen Einschätzungen und
Berechnungen liegt natürlich eine
wesentliche Annahme zugrunde nämlich
dass die westlichen Waffenlieferungen
weitergehen also wenn die aufhören hört
die Ukraine auf das muss man mal ganz
klar sagen und sie haben jetzt viel
gesprochen über die Kosten der
Unterstützung der Ukraine aber man muss
die Kosten auch relativ sehen nämlich zu
dem Szenario dass Russland tatsächlich
gewinnt also sich durchsetzt das heißt
das Ende der Ukraine als Staat die
großflächige Besetzung ähm und dann
überlegen Sie mal was das für Kosten
verursacht dann haben wir ich weiß nicht
wie viel Flüchtlinge aber sagen wir mal
15 bis 20 Millionen sie können sich
vorstellen wo die hinkommen ähm dann
haben wir ein Russland das an der
polnischen Grenze steht und ähm
überlegen Sie mal was das für Kosten
dann verursacht nicht nur für Europa
sondern auch für die Amerikaner also
dann haben wir wirklich wieder Kalten
Krieg und zwar massiv und ähm ich denke
schon wenn man das so mal ansieht dann
bekommt der Westen seine Sicherheit
eigentlich zu einem sehr sehr günstigen
Preis wenn sie mal vergleichen was in
die Ukraine bisher hineingeschoben wurde
also sprich Waffensysteme die das Ende
ihrer Lebensdauer erreicht haben das
gilt z.B für die Leo Panzer das gilt für
die Abrams paner das gilt für attackams
das gilt für glsdb was jetzt kommt im im
Januar also es ist ja nicht so dass das
modernes Hightech wäre sondern das sind
Arsenale die man in den 90er Jahren den
Nuller Jahren gebaut hat und wo man sagt
okay eigentlich sind die ausgemustert
aber da kann man sie noch verwenden
so und selbst mit diesem relativ kleinen
und passiven an Satz erreicht man schon
in der Ukraine große operative Wirkung
das liegt nicht nur an den ukrainischen
Streitkräften es liegt vor allem daran
dass die Russen eben die gleichen Fehler
immer wieder machen unfähig sind zum
Gefecht der verbundenen Waffen jetzt
überlegen Sie sich mal was möglich wäre
wenn man die Ukraine wirklich massiv
ausstatten würde mit Artillerie mit
luftkampfmitteln und so weiter das war
genau das Problem des Sommer 22 ähm man
hat Russland die Zeit gegeben um
Grabensysteme und Minenfelder äh zu
bauen einzurichten und damit hat man die
de facto den Krieg verlängert so jetzt
ist halt die Frage was was will man
haben also will man eine freie und
unabhängige Ukraine weil sonst macht es
ja auch keinen Sinn
eubeitrittsverhandlungen zu liefern dann
muss es eine Ukraine sein die sich
militärisch in diesem Krieg gegen
Russland bewährt denn sonst geht sie als
Staat unter und das bedeutet
man muss darauf hinarbeiten dass die
Ukraine wiederhergestellt wird in ihren
Grenzen von 1991 oder man sagt tja
Ukraine ja ist mir eigentlich egal dann
wird dieser Krieg Z Gunsten Russlands
ausgehen dann steht Russland an der
polnischen Grenze und dann kann man ganz
Westeuropa wieder aufrüsten und dann
können sich die Amerikaner aber auf eine
Haushaltsdebatte gefasst machen weil was
dann an Milliarden Beträgen da so
rauskommt das will ich lieber gar nicht
wissen und dann ist übrigens auf Schluss
mit Pivot to Asia ne weil das muss man
ja nebenher auch noch finanzieren so
also in in dem Zusammenhang muss man das
ganze mal sehen was sind die Kosten in
Verhältnis zu welchem operativen
Ergebnis und vielleicht habe ich das in
der Vergangenheit noch nicht deutlich
genug gesagt also auch hier wieder Gruß
an meine russentrolle aber Russland ist
der Feind falls Sie das noch nicht
gemerkt haben Russland ist
das Gegenmodell zu unserer westlich
freiheitlichen Ordnung und es setzt
diese gerade in der Ukraine unter Druck
nach dem Motto schauen wir mal wie wie
stark wir draufhuen müssen die die
feigendemokraten im Westen die werden
schon irgendwann aufgeben und dann
errichten wir wieder unsere sogenannte
Einflusssphäre dann geht's wieder zurück
ins Jahr
1987 so das sind die H en Realitäten
denen sich der Westen gegenüber steht
und ich glaube den Leuten ist noch nicht
bewusst in was für einer Tragweite das
stattfindet und in in was für einer
welthistorischen Stunde wir uns im
Moment befinden was mich immer so so
fasziniert ist dass die Medien den Krieg
so ein bisschen auffassen als soap opera
ja also wenn wenn die Ukraine mal wieder
Erfolge erzielt dann herrscht Euphorie
und wenn sie mal irgendwo wieder zwei
baumlinien verliert dann herrscht der
Panik und um Gottes Willen Russland
gewinnt ich würde doch wirklich nahleen
das ganz von von dieser historischen
Perspektive auszubreiten worum es hier
wirklich geht nämlich nicht irgendwelche
Geländegewinne oder nicht irgendwelche
Artillerie Statistiken sondern es ist
eine fundamentale ideologische
Auseinandersetzung welchem System Europa
künftig angehört und wenn sie wirklich
indifferent sind gegen der gegenüber der
Ukraine dann ist das implizit eine
Unterstützung der russischen Position
das ist
sicher eine ideologische
Auseinandersetzung trotzdem muss man ja
sagen dass diese Debatte gerade anders
geführt wird als noch vor einem Jahr ich
meine jetzt war selenski am Dienstag in
Washington und wurde da nicht mehr mit
Standing Ovations begrüßt und das fragen
sich auch viele User hier gerade im Chat
hier fragt jemand
Biden sagte wir versprechen die Ukraine
so lange mit Waffen zu beliefern wie wir
können was erwartet die Ukraine wenn
dieser Fall eintritt ich denke hier der
Fall dass die USA nicht mehr kann
und wer kompensiert den Ausfall wäre so
eine Kompensation überhaupt möglich mm
ja sie kennen ja den Spruch ich ich
glaube er ist von Churchill die
Amerikaner tun am Ende immer das
richtige aber erst nachdem Sie alle
falschen Optionen durchprobiert haben
ähm und so ein bisschen erscheint mir
gerade auch die die US Innenpolitik also
gut die US Innenpolitik ist immer ist
immer Messi und und chaotisch ja das ist
schon klar aber wie gesagt
das was ich vorhin gesagt habe die diese
Rechnung gilt natürlich primär für die
USA und die USA müssen sich natürlich
schon überlegen was das heißt ne also
spar ich jetzt ein paar Millionen
dadurch dass ich dass ich 30 Jahre alte
Waffensysteme nicht liefere ähm und und
nehme ich dafür äh nehme ich dafür in
Kauf dass Russland sich vorschiebt an
die polnische Grenze also die die
Diskussion die ist absurd und die
braucht man gar nicht führen ähmo worum
es natürlich geht ist ist die übliche
innenpolitische Auseinandersetzung äh
dass dass man eben versucht äh möglichst
viele politische Zugeständnisse zu
erpressen von Seiten äh der der
Gegenpartei dafür dass dann die
Regierungspartei
irgendwelche Projekte durchsetzen kann
also ich denke das ist das übliche Chaos
der Innenpolitik aber was man auch sehen
muss ist es gibt eine nahtlose
Außenpolitik der
US-Administration gegenüber der Ukraine
und man man sagt ja immer um Gottes
Willen wenn Trump wieder Präsident wird
und so weiter beliebte angsterzählung in
den Medien aber man muss auch eins
dananz sagen es war die Trump
Administration die nach Minsk i die
Ukraine begonnen hat aufzurüsten also
sie auszustatten mit mit javelins und
enlaws ihr Militärberater geschickt hat
ihre geholfen hat ihre Armee zu
reformieren ihnen Kampftaktiken
beigebracht hat und so weiter alles
unter der Trump Administration also man
man darf nicht so den Fehler machen die
die politischen Figuren also die
Präsidenten der USA und und die
politischen Kämpfe im Senat oder im
Repräsentantenhaus ähm zu verwechseln
mit den eigentlichen geostrategischen
Interessen der freien Welt und
es es gibt ja solche die Sagen in der
Ukraine findet ein Stellvertreterkrieg
statt meistens sind das Russen Trolle
oder oder russische Propaganda ähm aber
das das ist nicht so sondern hier wird
ein souveräner Staat überfallen von
einem Staat der das genau gegenteilige
Modell äh einer freien Weltordnung
vertritt ein Staat der sich nicht
kümmert um das Völkerrecht nicht kümmert
um die souveräne Gleichheit der Nationen
nicht kümmert um das westfähische
Prinzip sondern einfach regiert nach dem
Motto das sogenannte Recht des Stärkeren
das hat in der Welt zu herrschen so und
wenn die Amerikaner sich noch halbwegs
in den Spiegel schauen möch nach diesem
Krieg dann müssen Sie jetzt das betonen
was sie immer betonen the Constitution
also sprich die die amerikanische
Verfassung ist ja nicht nur ein
innenpolitisches Werk sondern sie ist
auch ein ideologisches Werk in dem Sinne
dass sie sagt prinzipiell gilt hier die
rule of law also die Bindung der Macht
an das Recht und wenn man diesen
Gedanken überträgt auf die
internationale Ordnung dann können die
Amerikaner so etwas nicht tolerieren
vielleicht ist Westeuropa schon zu
dekadent geworden und und kümmert sich
um sowas nicht mehr aber wie gesagt wenn
wenn Sie das zulassen dann würden sie
damit aktiv einen Hegemon schaffen auf
der eurasischen Landmasse der den
Großteil der Ressourcen und der Menschen
kontrolliert oder zumindest unter Druck
setzen kann das wäre die größtmögliche
Bedrohung Westeuropas und wenn das so
wäre dann wird's wirklich teuer für die
Amerikaner wir haben dazu auch eine
Frage aus der Community Herr K würden
sie die Meinung teilen Russland setzt
alles ein um Geländegewinne zu erzielen
dann nächstes Jahr Wahlen anstehen und
Putin Erfolge braucht
ähm also den bei dem ersten Teil der
Aussage würde ich zustimmen ja Russland
setzt massiv Reserven ein um irgendwo
einen operativen Durchbruch zu erzielen
das stimmt schon also sie wie in AF
jefka wie ich erklärt habe sie werfen
massiv Ressourcen rein bisher scheitern
sie aber mit dem mit dem Vormarsch also
es gibt nicht irgendwo einen größeren
operativen Durchbruch der zweite Teil
also die der also die Worte Wahlen und
Russland in einem Satz zu nennen das ist
heute äh schon ziemlich sportlich also
die die sogenannten Wahlen
sind ungefähr so demokratisch und und
gleich und geheim wie in der Sowjetunion
ähm nein also das ist völlig egal wie
dieses Ergebnis ausgeht oder der Prozess
es steht sowieso schon fest also mit den
Wahlen hat es hat es sicher nichts zu
tun wenn wir gerade schon mal bei der
russischen Seite sind äh lassen Sie uns
mal auf dieses russische Video
gucken genau wir sehen hier ähm wie
Panzer an die Front verlagert werden und
das ist altes Gerät das sind T64 Panzer
die angeblich schon längst verschrottet
sein sollten was sagt uns das denn über
den
Zustand des russischen Geräts Herr Kolb
na das sagt uns zwei Dinge das das eine
ist ja das was ich seit März diesen
Jahres gesagt habe ähm die einsatzfähige
Reserve also spricht das was Russland
vor dem Krieg an an einsatzfähigen
modernen Systemen hatte also das heißt
t72 und alles was nach dem t72 gekommen
ist also T80 t80s T90 und so weiter und
die Varianten des T90 die neigen sich
langsam dem Ende zu und jetzt müssten
sie eigentlich in ihre Rüstungsindustrie
hineingehen und nachproduzieren bzw die
eingelagerten Bestände von t72 und
neueren Systemen aktivieren dafür haben
sie aber nicht die Kapazität also was
machen Sie sie werfen ältere System
an die Front also wie z.B hier den T64
wir haben auch schon bestätigte Bilder
von t62 und sogar schon von einem T55 an
der Front gesehen ich nenne das ja immer
scherzhaft Eskalation nach unten es gibt
ja diejenigen die sagen russland habe
die eskalationsdominanz und ich sag dann
immer ja ja nur auf der technologiekurve
geht's halt dann leider nach unten also
wenn ich solche Videos sehe dann dann
interpretiere ich das eigentlich als
Bestätigung dieses Effekts die die
einsatzfähigen modernen Systemen sind
langsam d abgeschossen so und solange
sie nicht die industrielle Kapazität
haben um massiv neue moderne Systeme
nachzuschieben was machen Sie sie
greifen ins Lager und schieben ihre
Altbestände nach also sprich was von den
sowjetischen Beständen noch übrig ist
und jetzt ist halt die große Frage wie
groß sind noch diese diese Altbestände
aber ger mal 60 000 ernähendt
Kampfpanzer von dem Niveau sind wir
längst weg aber was da noch in in
irgendwelchen sibirischen Depots
rumsteht das ist halt letlich
Spekulation genau das ist Spekulation
und das ist Altgerät aber sagt das nicht
auch dass die russische Armee hat mehr
hat als von vielen Experten ursprünglich
erwartet
wurde ja da das hängt davon ab was Sie
mit mehr meinen ne ich sage ja immer
Anzahl ist nicht gleich Einheitswert
also nur weil sie weil sie 1000 Stück
irgendeines Altsystems haben heißt es
noch lange nicht dass es operative
Wirkung erzielt ja sondern das ist dann
die Frage wie setzen Sie das Ganze ein
ähm in in welchem Szenario hat es eine
Chance gegen gegnerische Systeme wenn
die Russen ihre Panzer weiterhin so
verheizen
wie sie es bisher getan haben mache ich
mir eigentlich keine Sorgen ähm wenn Sie
diese Panzer direkt gegen Leo 2 oder
auch nur Leo 1 einsetzen würden dann
wäre das ein Kampf auf sehr ungleichem
technologieniveau was man machen kann
ist man kann die Panzer als
artillerieersatz nehmen also man kann
sie eingraben im Boden und dann wie eine
artilleriekanone verwenden aber das ist
eigentlich nicht die Idee eines Panzers
die Idee des Panzers ist Beweglichkeit
und Vorstoß nach vorne ähm also spricht
das das ist eigentlich das warum ich
sage Putin hat ein strukturelles Problem
von dem man nicht von dem er nicht
wegkommt er kann Reserven nachschieben
ja klar er kann weiter Stück an die
Front werfen aber das heißt nicht dass
er damit Einsatzwert erzielt und das
sehen sie eben in auf die jfka ne sie
opfern Material hin aber sie haben nicht
wirklich irgendeinen Gegenwert dafür und
das kann er machen bis alle Lager leer
sind ich ich ermutige ihn sogar das zu
tun es ist ein großer Beitrag zur
Abrüstung Eurasiens ein großer Beitrag
zur europäischen
sicherhe sie sprechen jetzt von einer
esal ation nach unten bei russischem
Gerät und sagen ja dass die Ukraine wenn
sie etwas nachbekommt Modernes
westliches Gerät nachbekommt jetzt ist
es ja aber auch so dass in der Ukraine
lang nicht alles ankommt was vom Westen
versprochen wird bzw nur sehr Zeit
verzögert sind sie damit nicht auch ein
Stück weit zu
unkritisch na das würde ich nicht sagen
es es hängt davon ab was Sie für ein
Waffensystem anschauen also es stimmt
dass es Verzögerungen gibt die sind
teils politischer Natur teils
technischer Natur also jetzt z.B bei Gl
also ground Launch small diamer bombs
das sind diese diese
raketenartillerie Dinger mit 150 km
Reichweite die sie aus den heimarystem
abschließen die sollten eigentlich im
Oktober kommen kommen jetzt erst im
Januar vermutlich wegen
Sicherheitsbedenken weil man erstmal
gucken will dass die Raketenmotoren
überhaupt verlässlich sind weil das sind
30 Jahre alte Systeme man hat zwar viel
davon 17 000 aber trotzdem safety first
oder das ist ein
Grund andere Dinge die da hat man die
Lage voll man will sie aber nicht
liefern aus aus irgendwelchen
politischen Erwägungen da muss ich sagen
ja ist ist nicht meine Sache die Politik
zu kritisieren äh militärisch wären die
Bestände da wenn die Politiker das nicht
wollen dann sollten Sie die Fragen und
nicht mich ähm und bei bei manchen
Systemen hat es hat es logistische
Gründe ähm einfach wenn also es gibt ein
eine Zeitverzögerung zwischen wann ist
ein System zugesagt und wann ist es
operativ einsatzfähig ne also z.B das
sehen Sie bei den kampflugzeugen die
kamplugzeuge sind zugesagt sie sind auch
da in Rumänien die Piloten trainieren
damit aber sie haben einfach eine
gewisse Ausbildungszeit bis diese Dinge
dann operative Wirkung
entfallen entfalten das werden wir dann
ab dem Frühjahr sehen also ich bichte
mal März April werden die F16 dann
einsatzfähig sein aber das das ist kein
Widerspruch sondern das ist halt der der
Masse und der Kompliziertheit
militärischer Logistik geschuldet ich
habe hier noch eine Frage aus der
Community hier schreibt jemand auf
Youtube überall rücken die Russen vor
und gewinnen an Boden ich versteh ver
stehe das nicht ich dachte die Ukraine
wird den Krieg gewinnen aber die Russen
drehen jetzt erst richtig auf warum habt
ihr euch so
geirrt also ja da frage ich mich was was
bezeichnen sie mit dem Wort aufdrehen ja
ich glaube da sind sie so ein bisschen
Opfer der russischen Propaganda geworden
oder haben haben zu viel telegram Videos
geguckt es es ist schon so dass dass die
russischen milblogger sehr sehr laut und
freudig dann verkünden wenn man wieder
eine eine treeline also so eine
baumlinie vor berückt ist es stimmt
schon dass es
im Moment eine Bewegung gibt an
verschiedenen Sektoren der Front wo
Russland leichte Geländegewinne erzielt
nur müssen sie das halt im Verhältnis
sehen erstens zur abnutzungsrate ähm die
enorm ist sowohl bei Personal wie auch
bei Material und zweitens zum operativen
Wert dieses vorrückens ne also nur
dadurch dass sie irgendwelche
Geländestreifen einnehmen oder zwei
baumlinien vorrücken haben Sie noch
keinen operativen Wert äh erzielt es
kommt also das sage ich immer wieder es
kommt in diesem Krieg nicht so sehr auf
die mechanische Komponente an also wer
hält im Moment wie viel Gelände sondern
es kommt darauf an wer die enorme
Abnutzung dieses Krieges länger
durchhält und wer die Logistik besser
organisieren kann das das sage ich auch
immer wieder wenn wenn Militärs sagen ja
Pfeilchen rot Pfeilchen blau und
Pfeilchen rot rückt vor es geht hier
nicht nur um filchen rot versus blau
sondern dieser Krieg hat eine technische
und logistische Komponente die man nicht
ignorieren
darf und wir haben noch eine letzte
Frage aus der Community hier fragt
jemand wie soll das Demokrat Europa
gegen die Kriegswirtschaft Putins
bestehen Produktionskapazitäten sind
doch bei den Russen deutlich größer ah
ja ja klar deswegen gehen sie auch nach
Nordkorea und holen von dort die
Artilleriemunition ne und deswegen
beziehen sie ihre drohen aus dem Iran
mhm ja ist total glaubwürdig das
Argument also wissen Sie wenn Sie sich
wirklich mal mit der russischen
Rüstungsindustrie beschäftigen dann
haben sie vor allem zwei Probleme
erstens Korruption zweitens
systematisches fälschen der Zahlen nach
oben war schon in der Sowjetunion so hat
sich nichts geändert
ähm ich glaube nicht dass Russland die
produktivkapazität hat um erstens massiv
aufzurüsten und zweitens genügend
Nachschub an modernen Systemen an die
Front zu liefern wenn Sie das könnten
hätten sie es längst getan Putin
inszeniert sich natürlich sehr gut ne
wenn er z.B sagt künftig 6% des
Staatsbudgets m in die Rüstungsindustrie
ich muss dann immer lachen und sagen ja
ja von den 6 % gehen mindestens 50 %
durch Korruption verloren aber sot
glauben wir es ihm mal ähm nur dadurch
dass sie dass die irgendwelche Gelder
sprechen oder irgendwelche propagandavos
in in äh Omsk oder sonst wo
äh drehen in diesen panzerwerken heißt
es noch lange nicht dass dadurch
operative Wirkung herauskommt es es
zeigt aber wie wirksam die russische
Propaganda in Europa ist und wie wie
sehr sie immer noch von vielen Menschen
geglaubt wird und eine abschließende
Frage habe ich noch ich glaube es ist
ziemlich klar geworden in den letzten 40
45 Minuten dass sie die Ukraine klar im
Vorteil sehen sie sagen auch Putin
bleiben noch rund 100 Tage wie kommen
Sie denn auf diese sehr klar formulierte
Zahl ja das das ist die Extrapolation
der abnutzungsrate also ich ich habe ja
immer mich bezogen auf die auf die
Schätzung des iiss und des schwedischen
foi
die die einsatzfähige Reserve Russlands
vor dem Krieg abgeschätzt haben und wenn
sie den Durchschnitt bilden dann kommen
Sie auf eine Zahl von etwa 2900 lau der
orix Liste sind wir bei jetzt etwa 2450
wenn Sie also die ähm die
durchschnittliche Verlustquote der
Russen die nach wie vor liegt bei fünf
Panzern pro Tag ähm und hochrechnen oder
dann dann würden Sie sagen okay ähm bis
zu dem bist zu der einsatzfähigen
Reserve die damals berechnet worden ist
fehlen noch 500 geteilt durch fünf
Verlustrate pro Tag haben sie noch
ungefähr 100 Tage das heißt jetzt
vorsicht nicht dass dass die Trolle mich
wieder hier missverstehen und und dann
wieder hetzartikelchen schreiben das
heißt nicht dass der Krieg in 100 Tagen
vorbei ist ja sondern das heißt dass in
100 Tagen ein entscheidender Punkt der
Abnutzung erreicht ist und ab dann
müssten wir eigentlich das massive
nachschie von Altem und sehr altem
Material sehen also genau das was sie in
imem Video Einspieler gezeigt haben ne
und ab dann findet eben dieser Krieg
zunehmend als als Differenz von zwei
verschiedenen technologieniveaus
statt Herr Kolb danke dass Sie meine
Fragen und die Fragen unserer Community
beantwortet haben schönen Abend noch
nach Zürich und bis bald gerne Ihnen
auch schönen Abend
danke ja und auch euch danke ich für
eure zahlreichen Fragen und Kommentare
ich werfe gerade noch mal einen Blick
rein und hier sagt jemand nicht die
ukrainische Offensive ist gescheitert
sondern die westliche Unterstützung und
jemand anders sagt es müssen halt mehr
Waffen geliefert werden und wir müssen
endlich auf Kriegswirtschaft umstellen
Wandel durch Handel hat versagt wie es
an der Front weitergeht wie es in der
Ukraine weitergeht und ob in 100 Tagen
ein kritischer Punkt erreicht ist ihr
werdet bei ZDF heute live erfahren
schönen Abend noch und danke für euer
mitmachen